I actually want to ask you how many
episodes is the show I'm glad you asked
there are 12 there are a dozen episodes
of the world according to Jeff Goldblum
that come out on Disney Plus starting
November 12th before that's a Tuesday I
believe and then the the cub the next
Friday is the second episode but then
every Friday after that you gotta wait
once a week for all 12 episodes so I saw
the first two last night what do you see
I saw the sneaker episode and the
ice-cream episode yes sir they were both
really both were great I think yes I am
totally looking forward to seeing the
rest that's wonderful to hear because
nobody's seen it really you know you're
one of the few few first people who've
seen it I'm so glad to diverging I will
say to you that anyone who's watching
this who ends up watching the ice cream
episode
you better have ice cream in the freezer
because as soon as I finish that episode
I went right to my freezer and started
eating so yeah thanks a lot Jeff you're
so welcome what flavor did you have in
your freezer uh it was like a vanilla
caramel something a rather it was very
good screaming I had denied myself ice
cream below these many decades because
I've been you know maybe a bite here or
there but you know I ate more in that
show and yeah and we visited that USS
America we visited the brave men and
women of on that aircraft carrier and
brought them because they have ice
creams I didn't know they brought ice
you know they have ice cream socials to
you know ease their loneliness and
difficulty and to great challenges you
know and it's somehow ice cream has the
power to be nostalgic and make them feel
good I I am curious did you film all of
these at the same time or were you
filming an episode taking a break and
coming back no no you they it was a
lovely schedule rigorous but lovely I
didn't want to be away from my wife and
two kids I got a little boy four year
old and another two year old boy but no
we kept going and it's sort of starting
to expand as we as we went and for the
last five six months we've been you know
I do I didn't leave home for more than a
week or so at a time and then I have a
little break back home but no we kept
going it was like a great summer camp of
kind or a couple season camp that took
me where I didn't wouldn't have gone
otherwise all over America the one thing
that I found like watching the sneaker
episode which I really enjoyed because
I've heard about sneaker culture but
this shown I've never seen like sneaker
column before before watching your
episode I didn't even know about it once
a year they have it and where did we go
in Baltimore I don't remember the city
but I did remember the amounts of wads
of cash that were on display it's
amazing I didn't know that you they
don't really exchange with anything but
cash so they had big bags of cash
they're paying on unbelievable amounts
for sneakers which are highly prized now
you know in the last couple decades
there's been an explosion of these
things I didn't know about any of it
it's amazing is you got a pair of I
forget the gentleman's name but you got
a very limited pair of sneakers one of a
kind
exactly he made he's called the denim
doctor and he there's no he's called the
shoe surgeon the shoe surgeon and he
made them for me bespoke we talked and
he included something personal in them
and they were absolutely amazing and
then we went to the headquarters of
Adidas which is how you pronounce
apparently Adolph dostler adidas was the
guy who I guess he dropped the Adolf we
went with Adi dust
we went up there and one of the things
we found out there technologically
speaking was they put a pair of glasses
on me and then they as you saw they gave
me the shoe a new shoe and instead of me
just saying well I wish this were a
little different this know know how I
feel about that this the glasses read my
hacked my inner thinking and feeling and
that's just the beginning of that
technology as I read to you fall Harare
and he says that technology will go
further and will soon be very hackable
by technology and be known more than we
know our own selves it's it's it was
crazy watching that thing but I'm
curious have you ever this the sneakers
you got gifted you are beautiful have
you ever worn them yes so you've worn
them out in public or just at home
that's so far just at home got it I
can't they're they're beautiful my
question is doing that episode did you
all of a sudden discover an inner
collecting if you will towards sneakers
or are you
now going to the shoe store and noticing
oh those those Nikes and those Reeboks I
need those uh here's the answer the
question the I have gone through that in
my life I've been sort of an obsessive
about a lot of different things denim we
do another episode on denim
I've dreamed about and then a awakened
must have I know the pants I know the
pants that'll change my life I know the
sneakers that I need because in my just
you know minimal you know why you know
exposure like I saw this somebody told
me about that I got to go there I'd find
myself in the car going to the thing and
then sometimes going that's it that's
the new that's the real me I've got to
get that in every flavor and then I had
collections of some shoes I never went
hog-wild I was never a Mel DeMarcos you
know or somebody I met yesterday with
100 pair of sneakers you know but I had
sneaker and then I wound up giving them
all away I like I'm because I there's
part of me that's very minimal aspiring
and so my current collection is pared
down pruned down and no and I have I'm
thrilled to say but maybe you may look
askance on it I have a stylist but many
people do and I trust him completely
we're in cahoots I like what I you know
but he says here's what you need so I
don't find myself going out and going
what do you think yeah give me ten of
them I'm not susceptible to that anymore
thanks to Andrew vote arrow he goes you
don't need that you don't need that here
this one will do the trick you know so
that's what I that's what I do but that
thing they made me included little
little things that were came from my
life personal things from my life I know
I gotta go but just real fast Jurassic
world 3 cannot I'm so excited you're
coming back Colin said that you have a
big part Colin Trevorrow is so wonderful
he she was gonna write and direct it
yeah I yes I have a nice part in it I've
been reading it every day working on it
and I'm eager eager to do it and get
reunited with sam neill laura dern Chris
and Bryce and I can't wait thank you so
much for your time cannot wait to see
the rest of the show I hope you